this is probably the most difficult
search ever undertaken
it is going to get more difficult we
seem to turn around and survey that the
ocean bottle to find it which will take
years
I do not believe the plane has crashed
on the 8th of March a plane carrying 239
people on board took off from the
Malaysian capital bound for Beijing it
was supposed to be a routine flight but
mh370 never reached its destination it
vanished without trace now exactly one
month on despite the biggest air and sea
search ever undertaken are we any closer
to solving one of the world's greatest
aviation mysteries maybe
film without ending heel today Chinese
patrol ship hay-zu no one discovered a
pulse signal with a frequency of 37
point 5 kilohertz per second at 25
degrees south latitude and 160 mh370
this is potentially the biggest
breakthrough yet in the search for the
airliner a Chinese vessel has reported
locating a ping possibly a signal from
the planes black box search crews were
surveying areas about 1,100 miles
southwest of Perth based on satellite
images showing possible debris the
Chinese say they've detected a pulse
just to the north and the frequency of
the pulse is 37 point 5 kilohertz
exactly what the flight data recorder
should be transmitting as if we're to
learn what happened to the Malaysian
Airlines plane then it's black boxes
must be found in the next 48 hours or so
the batteries that power the boxes were
dying
when that happens metal case keeping the
secrets of flight mh370 might never be
found it is going to get more difficult
from here one of the things if the black
box when the black box pinging runs out
which is actually a couple of days away
certified to it may last 40 days what
what we may then do is start an enormous
international effort to actually survey
the Indian Ocean floor it was last done
in 1960 it's one of the least no and
ocean floors in the world it may well be
they turn around so right we have to
turn around and survey the ocean bottom
to find it which would take years years
and used once the batteries are
exhausted
there's no sense and it provides you
know information so that's when you need
to look at employing different side scan
sonar systems and that's when the search
becomes incredibly slow flight mh370
left the airport in Kuala Lumpur for
Beijing after midnight on the 8th of
March but veered drastically off course
causing the search to begin in the South
China Sea on March the 9th we hear
reports that a Vietnamese plane has seen
a flight door floating off the South
Vietnam coast but we found out soon
afterwards that the object is actually
flotsam a March the 12th evidence from a
military radar forces the search area to
expand towards the Malak are straight
and the Andaman Sea where the focus on
debris continues but new information on
March the 15th places the jet anywhere
in one of two huge corridors of land and
sea a northern one stretching into
Central Asia and a southern one deep
into the Indian Ocean a March xx
Australian satellite images dated four
days earlier are released showing two
objects in the southern Indian Ocean
surveillance aircraft are dispatched to
the area and they discover nothing
two days later Chinese satellites spot a
large object floating in the Southern
Corridor but a plane Center collected
finds only clumps of sea
we'd and a wooden Palace then on March
the 23rd French satellites detect 122
floating objects around 1500 miles from
Western Australia but search crews from
Perth failed to find any wreckage from
flight 370 row
more debris continues to be discovered
over the next two days and a March the
27th we hear reports from Thailand of
300 floating objects taken only a day
after the French discovery but again
none were confirmed to be from the
missing flight our March the 28th and
29th the search continues in the new
area of the Indian Ocean as a Chinese
plane spots three multiple colored
objects and a cluster of orange objects
found by Australian pilots in the ocean
of March 31st raises hopes but I soon
revealed to be fishing equipment
unconnected to the plane so far it's
been a fruitless search marked by
confusion and a lack of information it's
expected the search will continue being
carried out underwater with the help of
the Royal Navy's HMS echo and
nuclear-powered submarine HMS tireless
there's a good reason there have been so
many false leads this body of water in a
southern Indian Ocean sucks in a lot of
ocean jumping
coin students me it appears that after
information that we know that the middle
of the ocean where they're actually
looking at at the moment in the search
area is also the middle of the Garbage
Patch so so they're looking for a system
that has this sort of natural
accumulation of of debris as well it's
not very much
we estimate about ten large items per
square kilometer but when you actually
look at the whole area it becomes a
large number and this is the Australian
Navy ship ocean shield just one of the
smaller model of vessels deployed in the
hunt to find conclusive proof of the
airliners face on board is a towed
pinger locator seen here being lowered
into the Indian Ocean also on board the
ship is a robotic submarine the
bluefin-21 seen here being hoisted back
onboard the ship after an unsuccessful
excursion for myself in the position of
any of the families I would certainly
want to know you know some of the
answers about mh370 so everybody is
totally focused on this mission of a
moment on board the ocean shield at the
moment we're certainly doing all we can
in the location we're at we're running a
series of parallel leaks over the best
constructed location of mh370 last
position but as advanced as these
crucial bits of Qatar they're rendered
useless if they're deployed in the wrong
location for weeks on and there's still
confusion about the search area and the
team's looking
are the teams looking in the right place
there's some positive sounds from from
the investigation team that they believe
they're looking in the right place with
the best information they have available
to them however it is their best
estimate it is not a precise science at
the moment
the relentless air search is taking its
toll every day the Aviators take to the
skies to fly of hours buff some of the
remotest water on earth it's taxing work
but they know they carry the hope of
hundreds of families desperate to know
what has become but despite the
frustration the search teams know they
have a job to do they'll keep going to
find something anything to give the
families from the remote location the
weather has been a real challenge
rough turbulent water makes spotting
potential debris hard enough but then
heavy cloud hampers visibility and for
an eyes on surge it means you are
literally flying blind today 11 things
will join the search mission weather
conditions today are very good but when
we fly back it will be a little windy
this is the search area you can see from
the satellite image that is very cloudy
near this area
coming up in part two are the Malaysian
authorities hiding something is there a
conspiracy to stop the truth about
flight mh370 from coming out
the longer it takes to find flight mh370
then the truth vacuum will continue to
be filled with speculation and
conspiracy theories
the planes pilot captain our meds ihara
Shah fell under early suspicion he has
close links to the country's opposition
leader and the planes disappearance has
been connected to a deadly political
protest is it a crime for someone to
know me is it a crime for someone who
believed in an independent judiciary and
not a corrupt or popeck system now
zaharie is known to me related to my
daughter-in-law I've met him number of
occasions and seemed to be very
passionate about democratic process
independent electoral process against
the fraudulent elections in 2013 Ibrahim
Anwar insists his connection to the
captain is being used as a smokescreen
to divert attention away from the
incompetence of the Malaysian
authorities there is an installation
called McCarney a red system near the
South China Sea operated by the Air
Force the government tilted a particular
the Ministry of Defence have not
explained why they have conceived this
very vital critical piece of information
when the flight reverted it to Malaysia
into the mainland crossing five
provinces
there's no reason as to why they are not
able to detect the flight movement the
second issue is an issue of national
security if you can allow this to happen
then it is a betrayal of the people's
trust you cannot depend on Anika
incompetent ministry to design and
determine our own security now they have
to explain if they can't then they will
have to tell us why this vital piece
informations being concealed to the
general public and international
community of course I'm very
appreciative and thankful even to the
Royal Navy for the efforts taken now but
the critical issues in peace of
informations know explain the system so
opaque and anyone questioning like me
doing so in Parliament and outside
Parliament are condemned to be
politicising or anti-national or not
appreciative of the Malaysian government
effort this is utter nonsense
today the Malaysian authorities
responded to the speculation let me
touch on some unfounded allegations made
against Malaysia these ugly allegations
include the extraordinary assertion that
Malaysian authorities were somehow
complicit in what happened to mh370 I
should like to state for the record that
these illegally allegations are
completely untrue as I've said before
the search for mh370 should be above
politics
and so I call all Malaysians to unite to
stand by our armed forces as they work
in difficult conditions with their
foreign counterparts thousands of miles
from home and to support all those who
are working tightly in the search for
mh370 it's this sort of confusion and
the ensuing claim and counter claim that
is added to the turmoil for the families
of the missing passengers vomiting angry
scenes like this
in the search for answers a group of
Chinese relatives flew from Beijing to
Kuala Lumpur the same route in Reverse
that mh370 was scheduled to take exactly
four weeks earlier the main purpose of
our journey is to demand evidence and
truth for our loved ones we are here to
see how it goes step by step because in
Beijing were totally desperate there's
nothing coming out of Beijing on
reaching Malaysia more demonstrations
anger right at the Malaysian authorities
storming one of the Airlines press
conferences believing information was
being withheld they have followed us
taking care of us very well
however we don't need to be looked after
we need to know the truth we need to
know where the plane is we don't need
someone to look after us in the face of
criticism over Malaysia's handling of
the crisis its Prime Minister visited
Pierce airbase in Perth in Western
Australia this has now become the
international hub for the search
operation here
he paid gratitude to some of the
hundreds of men and women working to
find the missing plane the resources and
assets being thrown at this mission are
formidable it's an unprecedented
international response to an
unprecedented crisis but when plane
after plane and ship after ship returns
empty-handed day after day and soon
questions about the sustainability of
this operation will have to be asked but
for now the Malaysian authorities
refused the place of time limit on the
end it's been almost a month since mh370
went missing the search operation has
been difficult challenging and complex
but in spite of all this our
determination determination remains
undiminished we will continue to search
for the same level of vigour and
intensity
we owed this to the families on those on
board and to the wider world we will
continue to focus with all our efforts
on finding the aircraft the girlfriend
of one passenger refuses to give up hope
Phillip would a fifty year old American
was returning to Beijing following a
business trip he was about to leave
China for good to begin a new life with
sera basic she was at home packing boxes
waiting for him to walk through the
front door when she heard the news I do
not believe the plane has crashed I have
yet to find any expert whom I've talked
to that off record has said that they
believe the plane has crashed everybody
believes it's been taken i absolutely
believe he's still alive I still feel
his presence I am NOT a metaphysical
weirdo I'm a very grounded practical
logical thinking person but I still feel
him in the same way I have always felt
him that has not changed
you know I am prepared for if something
else happens if if if tomorrow I get the
notice that they've indeed found the
wreckage of the plane and Philips body
is still strapped in its seat then I
will accept that and I will move along
and deal with grief and a normal
grieving cycle but but this is not a
normal grieving cycle we don't have
resolution and there's no proof and
everything that I've heard both with my
head and with my intuition points that
there is some other resolution I can
only do so much to impact the situation
at this point and the little I can do is
to have an ongoing conversation with
media and to continue to drive forward
the social media efforts of getting
individuals to engage through the
finding Phillip wood Facebook page and
things but the other side of my of my
feeling is of an increasing level of
anxiety that we don't have any further
progress on this I mean it's been
closing in on for weeks and we actually
don't know for sure anything different
than what we knew on the 8th we really
don't and I think we need a few more
truth seekers right now and a little
less jump on the bandwagon from our
governments and frankly in some ways
even our media there's no logical
explanation to support that this plane
was taken only to drop it into the water
there's none there's no evidence they've
found hundreds of pieces of debris none
of them are related to the plane you
know more and more we have to be a
little realistic here that says there's
got to be another there's got to be
another path that was taken
Sera's heartache is shared by hundreds
of other families waiting for news of
their loved ones
in all the passenger manifest included
12 crew and 227 passengers from 14
different countries including New
Zealand Australia Iran America and
Indonesia two-thirds of the passengers
were from China among the passengers 43
year old father of two Nikolay Brodsky
from Russia a professional diver and
athlete he had traveled from Indonesia
on a diving holiday with colleagues and
was making his way home when the flight
went missing also Fernando Calaca a 23
year old from Mumbai he was travelling
with his mother and father to Beijing to
attend his older brothers degree
ceremony their eldest son waited at the
airport for them for several hours
Rodney and Mary burrows were one of six
Australians flying on the plane and had
been flying to Beijing with another
Australian couple a friend of their said
they had planned the trip following
Rodney's redundancy the previous year
four weeks of false leads and four weeks
of dashed hopes
now a faint ping in the darkest deepest
depths of the southern Indian Ocean
could this finally be the breakthrough
that will help to solve the mystery of
flight mh370
you